you can make fun of anything right but
you called it shaming I want to know why
it's shaming I think well this is just
my suspicion can't prove it I think most
people subconsciously have a lot of red
tape about making fat jokes because I
don't think you would have kept that
energy if I was making short jokes I
don't think you would have kept that
energy or had the same reservations if I
was making a bunch of other stuff would
you uh
so a couple two weeks back I put uh we
put out a video in regards to
some woman who got upset because her
date saw her and then did a 180 and left
yeah I was supposed to have a first date
tonight and he just son matched me on
Bumble so I guess we're not going to get
drinks anymore but I thought I would
show you guys my outfit so somebody saw
it
um remember I was like looking in
something that I found out that the news
articles were fraudulent and that she
did in fact advertise how big she was
and so the dude who turned around left
when he saw her basically wasn't falsely
advertised based off the pictures that
she claimed she used on her Tick Tock no
I got so many comments on this video
asking if I was just posting selfies I
have to take my profile to all my
friends and be like is this what I look
like I want to make sure I'm accurately
representing myself
I'm not able to just post selfies like
thin people
how I even have a beach picture where my
stomach's out and you see my rolls so he
knew what he was getting into I
accurately represent myself on dating
apps because I have to as a fat woman so
we checked out the video we put out a
little Community posting so we're going
to cover in a future video so I thought
about we talked about it today and what
were your thoughts about the whole
situation yeah we need to do a video
about it addressing it but I find it
interesting that in another video
you said something about not for shaming
and this and that now whatever and stuff
and then we do that video
and then you call her all sorts of [ __ ]
sure
that's Amy
what do you mean I'm not for shaving so
as you said any previous video in
another video right when we're talking
about uh patchaming and stuff like that
and uh going out there you know people
being big and stuff like that and you
know you were not for shaming people and
you calling people names and [ __ ] like
that but then we do this video
and whatever we saw the face and the
body didn't match you went on an old
charade and took yeah yeah but that's
that's shaming you know yeah if you call
someone a whole ass whale you're shaming
that person for the way if you call
someone stupid is that shaming yeah it
might be depending on the situation if
you if you roast anybody is that shaving
it depends on the situation we're
talking about the context here I'm
talking about the context of course if
we take it out of the context calling
anybody anything is not okay exactly
well the context is what's important
what was the information we were going
on
the information was that she
missing someone into going into a date
absolutely right and then she revealed
what she actually looked like and I was
like yeah okay you can get this work
um there's a difference between
let's say you are led to believe that
somebody's a war criminal there's an
article that comes out and you roast
them you say you demonic son of a [ __ ]
you belong with Lucifer you're probably
eaten Satan's anus every day okay and
then it turns out that the news article
that you're reading is false well
obviously you're that person apology
because we said right but you also have
to acknowledge that like the medium for
which you normally rely on to get
information wasn't accurate right right
so I think the issue in this lies not
necessarily just in what was said but
more so how you handle afterwards right
video is up for an hour take it
immediately yeah a [ __ ] could have left
that [ __ ] sit
so you when you say so to address your
point about shame I think there's a
giant difference I don't go out of my
way to see somebody short
but if you're acting big chested and you
acting crazy yo my man lit homie
my Hobbit looking Lord of the Rings
[ __ ]
my Gollum crawling uh [ __ ]
crib you know then you can get that yeah
you get that word there's a difference
people say oh you can't make in front of
people no you can make fun of someone
kiss their fan
there's times when it's unwarranted I
want I want to put it out there right
you can make fun of anything right but
you called it shaming I want to know why
it's shaming no I wanna I wanna see
what's your position with that and I
mean because there is a difference in
the difference to make yeah yeah so so
because we did because we did that video
where we talk about that we need to make
we need to put it out there and be like
like I'll stand on I think well this is
just my suspicion can't prove it I think
most people subconsciously have a lot of
red tape about making fat jokes because
I don't think you would have kept that
energy if I was making short jokes I
don't think you would have kept that
energy or had the same reservations if I
was making a bunch of other stuff
absolutely would you no you're right you
wouldn't I said I you're right you
wouldn't have right I'm saying you're
right okay so that's my point I think
when it comes to absolutely fatness yeah
people all of a sudden add an extra
layer of perfection and they're just
like you know
get the [ __ ] out of here
we know what the [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying and so there is right right so
you're right on one hand I am sorry
because one I went at somebody who
didn't deserve it because like how many
times have people seen an article or
they hear a bunch of news coverage about
somebody being a child diddler yeah
people were off making all kinds of
watches absolutely if it turns out to be
not true afterwards nothing happens
should they apologize absolutely because
the person's name has been dispared so
you owe them that yeah however you're
going off the information that you have
we're not a news agency okay you can't
you can't have someone vetting all the
news articles to make sure the sources
are factors are accurate no one's doing
that but what we can do what we do have
a responsibility is if it comes to our
attention that we are incorrect about
something then you have to address it so
why do we have it where's that
disconnect not that disconnect I'm sorry
let me take that back where is why do we
have that that thing where we feel some
kind of way when we talk about fat but
not other people because
actually you know what actually you know
what no you could probably know hold on
fat woman
because fat man we don't give a [ __ ] you
a fat [ __ ] you're big dude man you fat
get your lazy ass we don't give a [ __ ]
about that right we don't care if it's a
fat dude if it's fat lady well [ __ ] we
got to be we got to be there's a bunch
of America preach get em free tell them
because body positivity ain't fermented
no it's not let let's be clear about one
thing body positivity body positivity
I'm not gonna say it body positivity is
not ferment it's not a thing that is for
men it's not a thing where men are
included yes they are made sometimes
sometimes some efforts but they're not
even some very body positive people are
like I don't want to go out with a fat
man well they say it yeah it's out there
is that yes a lot of you are going to be
like hey but I wouldn't care yes but
we're not talking about your exception
yeah we'll talk about most and you go
and you go out there [ __ ] don't
don't care and like we were mentioning
that in that other video there was a
whole Beauty passion about
uh body positivity and then it was one
rip dude in there
what was that no no you can't be having
one rip dude wearing slim fit swim thick
or whatever and you'll rip like that
they don't they don't connect so we know
that we know that's a fact but there's
other things like that height
you know I mean we're not we clown dudes
on height I'm just not sure where it's
from and why we do one and not the other
and we off and we don't address it it's
easy bro it's just we've convinced
society that
fat people are to be protected at all
costs they're dude coddled they're to be
treated like and I'm like no at the same
time you don't have to go out of your
way to do something but someone acting
crazy and they're gonna get this roast
energy they can get it on their fatness
too simple
that's it but if you're asking me where
it comes from it's because we've made it
red tape and Taboo in our society to say
so we've we are we are this whole body
positivity movement stems from that
emotion where it's like you know we're
gonna just talk like it's not a problem
and you being you know more believed it
is you being more the obese is a huge
problem okay but we're making it so we
can't talk it's a boogeyman yeah the
same way you can't talk about certain
forms of racism or whatever yeah very
similar so that's where it comes from if
you go in certain country and you talk
about what's going on there yeah yeah
yeah certain people are not gonna like
it but it is what it is yeah so so again
this is one of the I think one is one
fold uh twofold first you know you start
off with we [ __ ] what what I talk
about the amount of folds of the body
listen bro I was not making more fat
jokes I haven't said anything maybe this
is too big for you to accomplish you
still can't get the [ __ ] out of here
okay you slept well yeah you slept well
listen you got that energy I don't know
all right but moving past that
no no that's not even okay stop not
everything can be a fat joke I haven't
said anything big
[Laughter]
okay so all this to say
I think the real sad part is that we
can't rely on our media platforms to
report on things honestly which puts the
public in a very precarious position
because people say do your research it's
like well not everyone got the time to
do it not everyone got those all this
other stuff maybe I should hire a budget
I'm like man if you think I'm reading
every article then pass it through your
vetting system you know ethically I
think you can make the argument that
maybe we should and maybe that should be
a practice we go going forward but the
truth is you want to know what our
process is I see something on Google I
pick it up and then if it sounds fishy
then I'll look deeper into it but
generally I do most of the research on
these topics and so you know it's not a
deep dive it's like oh this looks
credible and then we move from there and
I'll try to look at the new source if it
looks half decent that's fine as long as
I'm not reading for something like the
onion.com like generally
most of these things go well but
sometimes subscribers point it out to us
and when they do we try to rectify
things right away but yeah that's where
I stand I think it's unfortunate in this
media cycle you can't rely on it because
apparently from one of the videos I've
seen from the girl she posted about the
fact that the news company in question
had acted like they quoted her and they
interviewed her when they never did I
got an email from
to use screenshots of a video I posted
that's gone viral because they wanted to
do a story about it the email was asking
for permission not sure why they asked
for permission because they posted the
story without my permission
and what's even crazier is the headline
like they interviewed me this is me I'm
curvy and proud but curl trolls say I
catfished my Bumble date when he stood
me up
um Chloe don't know you
but we never spoke I've never once
called myself Kirby
I don't use that term I'm plus size or
I'm fat
also when did I give you permission to
write a story about me wow so you're
seeing that there's a lot of
journalistic bypasses that are happening
and I think it's unfortunate because
even if you move past us okay let's say
this goes viral on social media like it
did before we saw it you can't expect
every party in the public to do their
research as well so we have a problem
being compounded both by influencers and
people in the media or YouTubers like us
and then also by Regular People such as
yourself who share it on media media and
make it grow organically to where we've
covered so
there's so much of that happening and I
think it's just I've I think it's
unfortunate we can't rely on I mean
anything I'm outside I mean I'm pretty
sure we're going to make sure that
we are going to do our job into looking
into information uh of course things are
going to slip up like you said it's
crazy that the news outlet that that's
their job and they have they actually
have some rules that in regulation that
they have to go buy into in order to
deliver a story where where YouTubers
but we still have we still have a sort
of responsibility towards that
that being said
yeah
we [ __ ] up yeah
and whenever we [ __ ] up we gonna say we
[ __ ] up
it's not a problem it's not a nation
that's fine yeah
anyways that's all I got to say yeah uh
leave a comment below with your best fat
joke and let us know what you guys think
all right back to big bigness